[Musique]
j'ai jamais vu le peuple iranien aussi
en colère que je les vois aujourd'hui
d'origine iranienne Chayan asgaryen
observe avec inquiétude la crise qui se
coulira avec une de mes amis qui vit la
ville de chiras elle m'a dit que il nous
coupe l'Internet encore le jeune homme
de 20 ans ne peut s'empêcher d'avoir une
pensée pour Massa Amini morte après
avoir été arrêté à Téhéran par la police
des mœurs elle a donné sa vie pour
le droit de s'habiller comme elle
voulait
mercredi après-midi des membres de la
communauté iranienne ont exprimé leur
colère par centaines dans les rues de
Montréal il faut que le gouvernement
canadien
comprenne que cette fois-ci il faut
soutenir le peuple iranien ça pourrait
être ma fille on n'a pas la liberté on
n'a pas la sécurité la situation c'est
tellement pire on ira surtout surtout
pour les femmes parmi les manifestants
cette sociologue et politologue né en
Iran et installé à Montréal depuis
plusieurs années la population iranienne
est vraiment habité par cette colère
sociale qui elle-même a été construite
sur une frustration sociaux économique
et politique un peuple divisé un peuple
exaspéré face à un régime quasi
impossible à déloger commençons ça va
écouter ça fait 40 ans que ce régime
gouverne en raison de cette répression
étatique très très forte
un moment donné même ces élans en fait
de révolte et de manifestations sont
vraiment écrasées et sont étouffés on
sent tous quelque chose est en train de
changer tout le monde le sent à mesure
que la colère grandit Chayan asgaryen se
laisse tout de même bercer par un
sentiment d'espoir j'aime vraiment que
ça soit un peu démocratique qui a une
constitution une constitution fait par
le peuple pour le peuple ici elle dit
assis Radio-Canada Montréal